[Música]
en lo alto de las montañas del norte de
Portugal cobas dubarroso este pueblo de
180 habitantes pronto podría encontrarse
cerca de la puerta de la mayor mina de
litio de Europa
Aída nació aquí El agricultor lleva 5
años luchando contra este proyecto
las minas que quieren hacer están a
nuestro alrededor empiezan aquí e
implican a todo nuestro pueblo
[Música]
desde el momento en que se instala una
mina hacia lo abierto que funciona las
24 horas al día y todo el procesamiento
se realiza en el sitio a pocos metros de
nuestras casas la calidad del agua y del
aire se contamina
la empresa británica Sabana está detrás
de la exploración promete varios
centenares de empleos directos e
indirectos en una región que vive
principalmente de la agricultura
los empleos que quieren crear son
empleos calificados y nosotros no
tenemos calificación para trabajar en
una mina además sería muy difícil para
los habitantes renunciar a su estilo de
vida la mina podría extenderse por más
de 500 hectáreas esto supondría una
amenaza para el paisaje clasificado como
patrimonio agrícola mundial aquí el tema
está en Boca de todos Hola hola
Qué le ha parecido a la manifestación
había mucha gente al lado de la
carretera todo el mundo hablaba de la
situación
la zona de seguridad de la mina
empezaría a 50 metros de mi casa y la
mina a 500 metros me siento triste me
siento mal
pensar en tener que dejar la casa que
construir con mi marido es muy doloroso
el litio de la región está contenido en
su suelo sondeos como este marcan las
zonas de exploración
Mira el agua es poco profunda este es
uno de nuestros temores todo el agua se
almacena aquí Qué pasará cuando ataquen
la colina
el estado de la capa freática preocupa a
estos ecologistas en una zona que
experimenta periódicamente sequías
para concentrar el litio tienen que
utilizar cantidades muy grandes de agua
dicen que reciclarán alrededor del 85%,
pero aún tendrán que Añadir un 15% más
de agua al circuito
al igual que cobas dubarroso todo el
norte de Portugal es el centro de
interés en total el país dispone de
60.000 toneladas de litio
un oro blanco que busca este equipo de
geólogos
hoy vamos a medir la cantidad de litio
presente en esta roca
y vamos a empezar por aquí
La Roca contiene espodumen de este
mineral se extrae el litio
si tomamos un metro cúbico de esta roca
obtenemos 300 kilogramos de espodúmeno
lo que basta para fabricar una batería
pequeña para un carro híbrido por
ejemplo
[Música]
Pero estas extracciones producen grandes
cantidades de polvo que pueden
contaminar el medio ambiente estas
explotaciones también recuerdan a otras
minas de todo el mundo criticadas
periódicamente por su consumo elevado de
aguas y productos químicos
hay que entender que en Europa Tenemos
los mejores estándares en exploración
minera y metalurgia
son mucho mejores que en China o
Sudamérica donde actualmente se extraen
las materias primas
en Lisboa el gobierno apoya el proyecto
de extracción con una subida de precio
del 7% en el último año el país se
considera líder en fuentes de litio un
mineral que Europa considera esencial
para alcanzar la neutralidad de carbono
en 2050
Aquí vemos las 8 zonas en las que se
llevará a cabo la exploración de litio
en el centro y en el norte de Portugal
son 2500 kilómetros cuadrados de
exploración prospección sí Portugal es
la mayor fuente de litio de Europa y la
octava del mundo
la transición energética implicará un
mineral esencial que es el litio
se utiliza para fabricar pilas y se
emplea en todos los dispositivos que
almacenan energía siempre habrá algo de
contaminación
pero el objetivo es minimizar su impacto
el proyecto de mina de cobas dubarroso
está a la espera de recibir luz verde de
la agencia medioambiental portuguesa en
los próximos meses